welcome back to age 20. so in this
section we want to define
events and frames
the goal is to define the principle of
relativity so let's think first about
what an event actually is
an event is something that happens
and it happens independently of the
frame of reference independently and how
we want to describe the event itself
we might use the frame a reference frame
to define the event but again the event
is an independent thing which happens
let's look at an example probably one of
my favorite example in this class
guess what happens
what
professor clutter exploded okay
really and then you start asking the
questions
when and where
when did it happen and where did it
happen but the event happens without a
description of the when and where
we can then
draw a reference frame as i did here
with an origin with an x-coordinate a
y-coordinate and a z-coordinate and in
this
in this picture
we have
a spot defined uh for the event and we
need to also have a fourth coordinate
for this the time in order to describe
when the event actually happened
and i did this here
in some coordinates i give you it's you
know 42 degrees north 75 degrees west
cambridge massachusetts at mit you see
mit the dome behind me
at 3 30 p.m on january 6 2021.
so i give you the when and the rare for
this event
i didn't give you the altitude for
example this is you know in this picture
maybe the y coordinate or the z
coordinate um but that would be needed
as well i i just tell you maybe my
office
on the fourth floor in building 24.
all right
so
when we want to consider an event
describing an event we have to consider
the space the where and the time the
when
and we can do this as a four-dimensional
vector a 4-vector a data set and so our
event professor clue to exploded
can be described with this
vector p
which has
an x-coordinate a y-coordinate a
z-coordinate and a time coordinate
all right so the important part here is
that events happen independent on the
frame of reference
um if you're sitting in
your in your room somewhere in in europe
right now you can describe
um this event
um with your time frame there's a six
hour time difference so the 3 30 p.m
would be
9 30 p.m in the evening
you can define your little room as the
the origin and then draw an x coordinate
y coordinate in z coordinate and
describe this specific event this
description will look different from the
description i just gave you
but the event is unchanged it's
independent of the choice of reference